what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna do a first
time watching today for the animated
movie starring a comedian I absolutely
adore Will Ferrell Megamind I've never
seen this I saw the trailer for this
years ago don't remember Jack about that
trailer but remember being like I'm
gonna watch it and I never watched it
with that in mind ladies and Gentlemen
please go ahead and leave a like that
would be extremely appreciated also uh
full length Reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy of
Megamind I'm actually gonna watch this
off Netflix right now is available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page I
just want to say a special thank you I'm
really grateful to everyone who has
supported and joined our patreon we were
one of those channels last Saturday
where there was a glitch on YouTube
completely lost all monetization even
had a new video go up that I spent like
several hours working on no monetization
on it so for those who pledge from that
video thank you thank you very much
patreon's literally saved us more ways
than once so thank you guys and we're
going to continue my hero Academia uh
sometime this week and we cover a bunch
of other shows exclusively over there
with the reaction that's watching lungs
included all right enough enough talking
let's get to it
[Music]
went to jail lost the girl of my dreams
and got my butt kicked pretty good oh
that's right
falling to my death oh wow my end starts
at the beginning
the very beginning
like birth like birth okay I came from
what you might call a broken home
literally broken hmm
oh it's got a Superman story you are
destined I didn't quite hear that last
part but it sounded important
that was the day I met Mr Curry Two
Shoes would this be what I was destined
for
a dream life filled with luxury
oh you dick a much different fate waited
me
what a place that taught me the
differences between right
and wrong
[Laughter]
it's given an opportunity to better
myself through learning like other
prisoners just kept the alien he had
already amassed a gigantic Army of
soft-headed groupies
oh he bought their affections with
Showmanship extravagant Gifts of
deliciousness
it's like if Lex Luthor was
misunderstood
he just wants love
that's when I learned a very hard lesson
evil is sent to quiet time in the corner
so fitting in wasn't really an option
he's just misunderstood no matter how
hard I tried I was always the odd man
out oh poor Brainiac if I was the bad
boy the
going to be the
boy of
nice our battles quickly got more
elaborate he would win some I would
almost win others
metro map
defender of matrosity is that the one
Brad Pitt voices
I really like the animation and this any
chance you could give me the time
oh looks like you're gonna miss it by
several thousand years that's JK Simmons
happy Metro man
I like the earlier era flare of this
this is
RR wow okay the stuff they make you read
on air that's unfreaking believable it's
crazy I wrote that piece myself what I
was trying to say was I can't believe
that in our modern society they let like
actual art get onto the news sounds like
Jonah Hill not love we're not in love
I'm not saying I love you hey I love you
whatever
poor Jimmy Olsen
yeah the animation has that like old
school Flair of Espionage to it with
comic stripped
whoa what are you doing guys it's me
it's the war you were right
I'll always be a villain
all right put your hands in the air
[Applause]
I get Homeland revives from this guy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Despicable Me as well away quick to work
who is this I was just Roxanne
predictable
predictable you're alligators yes
juvenile shocking off khaki oh
scary in it what's this one doing
okay the spider's new
fighter
oh even the smallest bite from arachnus
deathicus will instantly paralyzed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Don't Panic Roxy
[Music]
oh how fun Metro man approaching sir
it was all part of his plan
[Music]
hold on a second are they gonna pull
some like other guys fliparoo and Metro
man loses
you were in the real Observatory did you
did you smart thinking you've Fallen
right into my trap you can't trap
Justice it's an idea a belief of even
the most heartfelt belief can be
corroded over time Justice is a
non-corrosive metal but Metals could be
melted by this it's revenge and it's
best served cold but it can be easily
reheated in the microwave of evil well I
think your warranty is about to expire
maybe I got an extended one
but as if Metro man can withstand the
full concentrated power of the sun fire
this is embarrassing could someone
you love all people know
no promotion your Dark Gift has finally
paid off it it has
but obviously lined with copper yeah
so sir copper trades my Powers your
weakness is copper
oh no oh [ __ ] he won oh that's a
fascinating setup
what's the movie about that
what
no way I did it
what are you gonna have to live for now
that's a really interesting setup
good for you man
I can't swear can't swear can't swear
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh just look
did you think this day would ever come
no way no
not never never in a million I mean
now that Mr
shoes is out of the way I can have
everything I want and there's no one to
stop it oh dude but you have no purpose
now what's a villain without his hero
[Music]
ouch
no you can't is this gonna get like
really dark think about it
at all
yet we have nothing oh yeah you'd be
empty man it's just too easy now you
gotta earn it we did it right then why
do I feel so
Melancholy melancholy
you should come over I got a DJ rented a
bouncy house made a gallon of dip it's
gonna be sick I don't really feel like
being around a bunch of people no no
that's the best part it'll just be like
you and me creepy I did hire a wedding
photographer that's just in case we were
like something crazy happening if we
wanted a picture of it like maybe we
should have this for like ever like a
memory you know
um I'm gonna pass
oh this Roxanne girl is just treated
with so much disregard kidnapped
creepily hit it on
is there a way to resurrect him
or create a new hero or something I had
had the illiteracy beam
food that's stupid you know I never had
the chance to say goodbye it's good that
we have this time now
you know before I destroy the place
Holy balls
hello is someone there we're having the
walls and ceiling removed wow that
sounds like quite the renovation I guess
I'll um catch a ride down with you then
if only the world had a reset button
I've looked into the reset button
besides is impossible
didn't know you had
feelings are you okay just general
feelings as long
as I believe someone is going to stand
up to mega mind you really think so yeah
Heroes aren't born they're made
oh shoot he is going to make one I'm
going to give someone I don't know who
yet Metro Man's powers I'm going to
train that someone to become atrocities
new hero Mr Miyagi it's his DNA from
this we'll extract the source of
metroman's awesome power what if you end
up making him like a bad guy you must
find a suitable subject someone Noble
heart and Minds who puts the welfare of
others above their own Jimmy Olsen
I certainly building in Metro city with
a fake Observatory on the roof
[Music]
creation of science what oh no not you
Roxanne no I was just yelling at my
mother's urn
Roxanne whoa oh I better take the lead
this way looks exciting no it says Exit
uh which is the abbreviation for
exciting right
and that code said there's a braver you
know the whole point of a code is code
just do it a code
let him go or or what or I'm gonna find
out what this weird looking gun does
I'll just go get him
I'm happy you happy you've never is your
strengths too much
um I work out let go it's fine
you're gonna you're gonna turn him
no no no
there's
there could be evil in that guy
down
you were right about that door being
exciting
[Music]
yeah
anyone but Metro man stand up to him
like that oh my God I better take him
home
oh no this is bad that was weird for
everybody because you accidentally
hugged him instead of me
what's happening to the real Bernard
no no makeup to fall for her or has he
always been in love with her who is this
man
what's her his name's Hal Stewart he's
28 years old no criminal record
apparently this man hasn't accomplished
anything
not yet I don't like this at all this is
no mistake
that is a really funny physical bit it
doesn't look
such a pill minion
the Potter couldn't ask for finer clay I
like how they kept Mega mine with boyish
eyes
holy crap what's going on easy my child
who are you I sent you to this planet to
teach you about Justice
I am your father
so you're like my space dad
yeah I'm like you spaced that
I'm your space stepmom
I had some work done recently is this
some kind of dream this is a dream come
true
unfathomable power what kind of power
unfathomable it's on without fathom
to be atrocities new hero and battle the
Super Genius of Megamind it's a great
Marlon brand new impression it may take
months for you to come to grips
I wasn't finished
yeah this is a terrible idea
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
and brilliantly told by the way okay now
you tell one
I never heard you laugh
no this is so awkward
oh cool
it's like a Mario Donkey Kong level
[Music]
for everything I'm sad that we didn't
this is so bad this is Icky hey what's a
t stand for Titan
Titan what's that supposed to mean I
could be a villain's name do you have
someone special in your life how there's
this really really good looking one I've
got my eye on currently that's gonna
turn him evil
oh God it was a creep such a creep just
a few
black mama nicely done you've Fallen
it's actually a great shot who you
that's the point of lying the
oh my sole purpose in life is to look
after you well I don't need you to look
after me but he's
no you don't need me let me make it
clear minion loves you
I'll just pack my thing and go code my
thing and go well good
[Laughter]
bye
poor minion wait a minute
what do you see
Titan what how'd she do that my super
ears are burning
and I brought some flowers didn't know
what you liked so I just grabbed you
know all of them you stole them thought
maybe we could go for a little Flight
Around Town get to know each other first
I should just rescue you a few times
before we get all romantic whoops
[Music]
it's our creepy
wowza
[Music]
one you almost died
horrifying to do to her
cute clothes I'm a little crazy about
you who are you the animation is pretty
cool though
great
you are Disturbed this isn't right it's
Titan it's Titan not how
[Music]
oh my goodness
thousands of civilians on the ground
floor just died glass shards
perishing many families your hair looks
exciting not the only exciting
development of the night
how'd you make it down I'm sure we'll
get to the bottom of who's kicking who's
butt but in the meantime each other's
company I'm sorry to
being normal
hell of us you can just drop the topic
of conversation after that horrifying
incident let's say I was bald and had
the complexion of of a popular primary
color would you still enjoy my company
you don't judge a book by its cover or
person from the outside oh oh no you
judge them based on their actions
well that seems kind of petty
[Music]
oh my God this is so bad
[Music]
this is so bad
[Music]
don't look yet
ow this poor woman
has so mistreated this whole movie
that reveal came a little bit earlier
than I expected you actually made a care
about you why are you so evil
tricking me it was pretty messed up I
don't believe this
oh
mess the visitors get up a pillow pepper
this is conflicting
manipulating the whole situation I don't
think it's okay
gone man
[Music]
looks like Sinestro okay Titan it's time
to go down the style
Todd it's gonna be doing some evil [ __ ]
you're gonna become the good guy
foreign
[Music]
what is Titan doing were you even
planning on showing up
what's this
oh my God he's gone fulfilling I only
took the gig to get the girl and it
turns out Roxanne doesn't want anything
to do with
uxar having dinner and making googly
eyes at some intellectual dweep oh
you're the good guy I do something bad
and you come and get me that's why I
created you Odo I'm your space dad
also the intellectual dweeb dating
Roxanne bring me to Justice oh God now I
missed it oh God
you did not prepare yourself for this
you fell for the oldest evil trick in
the book
you little blue twerp generation is so
awesome oh my God oh my gosh right in
the
crotchy back and forth
okay look I'm not sure where to go with
that
[Music]
here's what's the space time making a
fool out of me
game over
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness
what have you given birth to megabyte
[Music]
[Laughter]
guess what Buster Brown oh no he can
withstand his catchy
foreign
thank you Titan has freed us more like
Under New Management
this is so bad
[Music]
house
ah I remember when he wore that let me
try to stay focused here yes of course
right focused
hey come over and look at this what is
it what did you find
this glass has ice cubes in it yes
that's what happens when water gets cold
no what I'm saying is
odd that the ice hasn't melted yet
no way hey
you jerk I did not see that coming I'm
alive
but we we saw your skeleton you were
dead are you a ghost Copper's not his
real weakness we we had done this same
silly charade our entire lives I tried
to get my mind off how I was feeling
each and every citizen of Metro had
something I didn't a choice ever since I
can remember I've always had to be what
the city wanted me to be it's like an
anime characters get bored copper brains
my Powers your weakness is copper
oh you dick finally free to get in touch
with my two power
[Music]
granted you have talent but there's a
Madman out there you know little buddy
there's a Yin for every Yang if there's
bad good will rise up against it
good we
AK layer grab some ray guns
[Music]
come on man unless someone comes to our
age soon all may be lost
thousands have already fled the city in
a mass Exodus French men should just
wear a mask you
know the Megamind I knew would never
have run from a fight even when he knew
he had absolutely no chance of winning
that is true it was your best quality he
has always had this the city
one hour
don't keep me waiting oh you perv Warden
wouldn't I am sorry what
to make Roxanne pay for my wrongdoings
apology accepted what
[Laughter]
this city will never financially recover
from all this damage you're living a fan
there is no Easter Bunny there is no
tooth fairy in
it
wow what an entrance you're a villain
all right
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
wow
this is crazy
they're back in the air Mega month
foreign
no
ah the perception looks like there's
only one loose end now
oh he's returned my death was
greatly exaggerated so
you're the punk I've heard about
I'm so proud of you
minion what surprise
he's the real hero
Megamind no way you know what's good for
you Titan you'll stay out of atrocity
you got it for good
but he could come back
and now all the people believe he's
still around
there's so many gaps in this planet
oh never mind okay everyone will see the
truth
but there's only one person I know who
calls this town atrocity you're not
gonna be laughing for long yikes
I'm really interested in this
I made you a hero you did the full thing
all by yourself
oh no you're gonna kill him no matter
what side you're on you're always the
loser that's just not true
[Music]
warm it up again
enjoy your flight
[Music]
exciting music so this is how it ends ah
yes normally I'd chalk this up to my
last glorious failure
but not today Holo
smart
thing about bad guys they always lose oh
he's not a bad guy anymore
you won well
I finally had a reason to win
you
[Music]
Ah that's touching that's some touch and
[ __ ] we've had a lot of adventures
together you and I we have minion we won
today
oh oh I'm going I think this this is it
I'm going going far away
what a drama queen
you know I'm feeling much better now
[Laughter]
back to positive feedback
that was brilliant
you're pretty good in white
there we go
sorry my friend
way to go little buddy I knew he hadn't
been
defender of Metro City probably also
should have rebuilt Metro man statue
[Music]
oh who has the answer but not to tell
you once again
[Music]
that's the answer right now just to tell
you what to get who's bad
that was awesome I thought that was that
was Tina Fey Jesus why could I not put
it together
where's the Goddamn sequel for this
movie okay apparently there's that there
is a scene
[Music]
oh this is
day of my entire life oh no worries I
forgot about him that was awesome let's
talk about it I thought that was great
sincerely that was awesome all righty
well guys
um I mean this sincerely I thought that
was amazing it was one of those movies
that
felt like it got better as it kept going
you know and he often don't get to
really say that about too many films and
sometimes even with animated movies
you're like ass there's parts of the
middle trunk I feel a little bit off but
as it progressed it got funnier and it
got him more emotional and it got cooler
and I mean what more could you want from
a film like this in some ways I feel
like mega mega mind almost to make a man
in some ways I feel like Megamind is a
little bit ahead of its time because
this corner of Netflix came out in 2010
and I feel like now if it came out it
probably would have been more
appreciated because you know one of the
stories I heard circulating around this
film is that it wasn't a box office box
office success
yet the critical and on interception was
not bad it was actually uh fairly well
received but it's obviously had more of
a Resurgence perhaps in the past like
year to two and it's a movie that's been
requested uh for the real rejects for
quite some time and uh then it was like
top 10 on Netflix one of the time I'm
filming this I was like you know what
yeah let's make some time to watch this
film and I see why it's garnered so much
appreciation you know like when you got
shows like boys and Invincible things
like that now on on the air which which
dealt so much with like deconstruction
of superheroes then you got something
like this where you know that was just
the beginning of the comic book
superhero movie boom that we now have
that has dominated the industry
when you look at what they do here it is
such a wonderful deconstruction like so
many ways the plot feels um you know
what if Lex Luthor had defeated Superman
and it even deals with that classic
conversation of like can there be the
villain without the hero you know that
often often debate that you do here was
running Lex Luthor and Superman than you
do here with like Batman and Joker you
know the great hero versus the great uh
villain uh so I I think like in terms of
honoring the superhero genre of the
comic book movie genre I think it did an
incredible job and their the animation
itself I think is ridiculously
phenomenal like this is 12 years old but
damn it looks so good there were still
so many sequences especially in its
actions whenever tracking shots that
we're doing there were so many sweeping
moments that I was in awe of I could not
believe how this looks ju this if this
had come out this year I would still be
saying the same thing they might have
fine-tuned a few more things sure but
for the most part hurt I still think it
looks Flawless it looks amazing and like
the way the city is realized like yeah
you do get vibes of something like The
Incredibles but it does feel like it's
doing its own thing and the way they
fleshed out the characters I mean first
off The Voice work is incredible it is
really really really phenomenal Voice
work because the way they match their
expressions with like everyone is so
perfectly cast even down to something
like a Brad Pitt who I know has been
making the headlines recently for all
the greatest greatest news in the world
but Brad Pitt is the kind of name that
like I I love the performer Brad Pitt
don't get me wrong but it is the kind of
name that when I hear Brad Pitt in a
voice over role like they only got cast
and he's famous probably still the case
but even he was like perfect for for
this role he did an exceptional job but
Will Ferrell is MegaMind I think the
intentional choice to constantly
maintain that hurt Lost Boy quality in
the performance in the Expressions make
mega mind the villainous appearance on
the outset but keep those like
sympathetic Lost Boy eyes within the
character from beginning to end help
complement the performance so well like
you you really feel like you you know
this character so early on as just this
boy who just feels like he's trying to
find something great and feels hurt and
wants love ultimately he's just that
character who really wants love and he's
not as bad as he probably sets out to be
but I love the kickoff point I just love
that kickoff point of and you know Lex
The Lex Luthor type villain defeating
Superman and then the twists and turns
that it did along the way like honestly
there were some things I was able to
sort of semi predict of that that seemed
a bit obvious to me of it looks like you
might actually defeat him and then it
made me go what's this plot gonna be and
then it took an interesting Turn For
What the plot would be of having Mega
might have this existential crisis and
then ultimately trying to produce a hero
because he can't feel fulfilled without
it's like trying to create some type of
external circumstances to fill fill that
void within him and then of course when
he starts creating Titan
in the way they set up Titan is so well
because they have the Hal character
played by Jonah Hill again wonderfully
cast perfectly cast for it you have the
Hal character
um initially he does come across like a
little bit creepy but they don't go too
full board creepy because you're like ah
he's kind of a little shy dweebish guys
trying to get the pretty you know girl
who who's definitely in like a higher
chair category than him he's trying to
get her but you know he's not ultimately
gonna land her so he does come across
creepy but it's also rooted in such
insecurity and that's what they do with
both of their characters both with
Megamind and with um Hal is they make
them both so insecure that you feel pity
towards them and even with Hal but they
plant the seeds just right so by the
time he does Turn full villain and the
way they are teasing that he there's a
villain within him waiting to come out
was really well executed it's this like
percolating villain within this guy and
I thought it was great so by the time he
does does turn and the stakes are that
high and then with the twists and turns
the ones I really didn't see coming was
that Metro man was still alive and and
the way they've revealed that was really
funny and I like the again it's sort of
an introspective take that they had with
Metro man of going through the motions
you know and it's like similar you you
do one of the great things that I think
comic book properties can often do is
draw the parallels between hero and
villain and with this film you know you
do have
MegaMind who after defeating Metro man
or at least thinks he does he's going
through the motions and then he needs
something different to feel more
fulfilled and then Metro man was already
going through that same path already he
was just ahead of Megamind on that curb
and I like that it led to a moment of by
allowing Mega Man to think he defeated
him in the path that it goes on I I
thought it was so touching for Metro man
to be hidden amongst the crowd and to
cheer him on like yeah you made the turn
because they could have just kept
battling for ages but the thing that led
Mega Man Down Mega minded down this how
many times have I said Mega Man during
this discussion about the center more
than once the thing that let Megamind
down the path of becoming a hero was
Metro man removing himself from the
pitcher I think it's pretty cool I think
there's something like more there's more
Nuance to this picture than I imagined
like walking into this I hear the voice
cast I hear Will Ferrell's in it I hear
Jonah Hill Brad Pitt I just expected a
funny film I wasn't expecting something
that was going to be filled with wonder
that was going to have like sweeping
animation like I bet there would be good
animations Dreamworks Animation so I
expect a good animation but I wasn't
expecting something that would leave me
in awe over what I was witnessing
also Tina Fey is Roxanne excellent oh my
God just another great character
she is treated like that type of you
know female character where the
mangocatter everyone wants her and
everyone's kind of mistreating her
doesn't really make an awareness about
that but by the end of the film I you
know I I can't help but I you know I
can't deny it I was like you know what
the friendship and chemistry that is
formed I do like that they did not end
this with Megamind and Roxanne
ultimately ending up together like when
I thought this movie had a real good
complexity to me was when the breakup
moment did occur because that's when I
was feeling all the feelings I was like
man no Roxanne's totally right to be
feeling this like this is manipulative
this is kind of disgusting and horrid
yet this movie is awesome having me feel
very very bad for Megamind at the same
time because you really get him so I
wasn't expecting to walk into a movie
where the characters were as fleshed out
as they are like they're really well
done I even really cared about the
relationship between Megamind and Minion
you know like that I just watched DC
League of Super Pets and I would I would
certainly rank this movie above that one
and you know they had it's kind of a
similar thing you know instead of is
Superman was left off with crypto after
being departed from Kryptonite
they get that right after being depart
from Krypton and here you know he's left
with minion as his little companion the
one to always be this unconditional
Force for him so I think the way they
flesh out that relationship was also
really well done maybe not one of the
most nuanced ones maybe one that's
played a little bit more for humor but
by the time they reunite I I thought
this movie was just balanced really well
it didn't Teeter too much I mean over
the top comedy for me and it didn't
Teeter too much and go into some like
dark nuanced territory where it lost
sight of the kind of family Vibe it's
actually aiming for I thought it kept
everything at the right pitch and kept
it exhilarating and entertaining so yeah
for what I want from my animated movies
I thought the animation was excellent I
thought the voiceover work was good I
thought there was better commentary than
I was actually anticipating I do feel
like this movie in a lot of ways was
ahead of its time I think if this had
come out now it'd probably be much more
appreciated for what it was ultimately
setting out to do who did Ben Stiller
voice he voice Bernard
what I have the IMDb pulled up in front
of me right now oh that's cool
anyway
yeah and you know like yeah the riffs on
the Superman tail I think are really fun
and uh I don't know what more can you
say I feel like everything was sort of
firing on all cylinders here and it was
also a really funny time so
yeah amazing superhero film and one that
I'm glad is at least being appreciated
now and according to here they have like
a a Netflix series in development that's
cool
um oh no peacock it's Series in
development okay gotcha
well I wonder if the voice cast is
returning you know is this intentional
there were Parts about
um what you may call it uh Metro man's
performance that's semi reminded me of
Elvis Presley did you kind of get these
guys kind of get the same Vibe that's
what I felt like it was and JK Simmons
is Warden
oh yeah I love the old comic strip flare
to this and uh I did find it like very
very heartfelt with some good lessons to
be learned too and it was a believable
turn for making mine like I like the oh
there's one thing I was sort of craving
from this movie is a tad bit of of that
little extra punch this is a really big
like this is a nitpick I I am craving a
tad bit of that little extra punch of
awareness of some of the situations kind
of like with Roxanne of how she was
treated but also you know it's like Mega
Minds being touted as this Hero at the
end of the day but I'm like really what
he did was solve a problem he caused so
all this destruction of Titan and all
this other chaos and everything like
while he had good intentions it
certainly backfired and turned into a
catastrophe putting all these people in
In Harm's Way in danger and maybe some
lives are actually cost but he's being
looked at as like this great phenomenal
hero when really it could have been
somewhere maybe like even like a some
joke that just acknowledged like well he
actually did cause all this you know so
that a little bit of awareness I think
would have just been that little Added
Touch a little extra spice for me but if
they did too much awareness throughout
it would have pulled me out but yeah
guys
um that's pretty straightforward
thoughts here I thought it was an
excellent film and I thought it was
really funny and uh wonderfully voiced
wonderfully animated great music and I
even like the needle drops they chose I
thought actually complemented the piece
well sometimes with these animated
Properties or any film in general
certain needle drops just feel like
they're doing it because they have the
license too and they could throw some
cool nostalgic music in there but I
thought the needle drops they had in
here were perfectly accustomed for every
scene so then that one little craving
that I had I thought this was great
yeah I had a I had a blast with this one
so ladies and gentlemen leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that Bell thank you to all who
followed us on patreon and hey let's end
this with a pic
Tyler Hague I just wanted to hop here
really quick and say thank you for being
the amazing gracious man that you are
like I'll be honest sometimes I get so
busy that I don't take enough time to
perhaps go through my social media
messages or go through the patreon
messages you know once in a while I was
like usually a few times a month I'm
like I'm gonna dedicate like an hour to
doing this whenever I come across yours
there's a part of me that does feel a
little bit bad for not getting back to
you earlier enough because you've been
with us for such a long time you've
gifted us with many amazing things and
you've just been this gentle giving
spirit this entire time you've been with
us and you're you're like the kind of
reflection I I hope a lot of our
audience can be like there's something
inspiring about the sincere nature that
you possess so thank you for being a
thank you for Lending us your spirit and
thank you for being who you are because
I don't take that part about you for
granted like there's not a single
negative thing I can say about you
you're there's something very beautiful
about whenever I get to interact with
you and I'm whenever I do take the time
to finally get back to people and
especially when I can take the time to
reply to you I
I always feel good at the same time to
be able to interact with you because
it's nice to be reminded of folks like
you out there who help support us so
I mean when I say I love you buddy thank
you
[Music]